in realtà il titolo che io avevo scelto
era viaggi nei misteri dell'universo e
in qualche modo cerco di
farvi
vedere come noi riusciamo ad andare
all'indietro nel tempo e andare a vedere
i primi istanti dell'universo cioè
quelli subito dopo il big bang e
praticamente in
in questo Noi abbiamo siamo riusciti
come è stato detto prima nelle
introduzioni a scoprire la particella X
vi spiegherò dopo per quale motivo è
così importante se noi oggi esistiamo e
abbiamo infatti
una massa e solo perché esiste questa
particella senza di lei tutto il mondo
imploderebbe non spaventatevi ma
purtroppo è così e quindi quando
quanto riguarda il mondo intorno a noi
che cosa succede vede tante forme e
tutte queste forme in realtà
hanno una matrice comune cioè uno si
chiede cioè un fisico sperimentale Cosa
fa cerca di capire quelle che sono le
i regolamenti che sono alla base della
natura e
la mia ricerca inizia con questo
è stato il regalo che ho avuto quando
era una bambina e avevo questa
propensione è stato un microscopio che i
miei genitori mi hanno regalato e andavo
per casa incominciando a tirare di tutto
dei capelli ai tessuti che c'erano in
casa per cercare di capire che cosa di
come era fatto l'universo la seconda
parte del mio
diciamo del la seconda motivazione
è stata che un professore e qui io ho un
ricordo meraviglioso del liceo
scientifico di Bisceglie che ha capito
la propensione mia verso la fisica Ecco
perché qui mi immagino che ci siano
anche parecchi professori penso che sia
molto importante il loro ruolo in questo
di far capire qual è la propensione di
una persona quindi la mia attività è
continuata con quello che avete sentito
E quindi ho preso
Lauria in fisica e dottorato di ricerca
presso l'Università di Bari e poi sono
approdata come dottoranda in quello che
chiamo il mondo ideale il mondo ideale
si chiamano Due entità il CERN cioè il
Centro europeo della ricerca nucleare vi
spiegherò poi perché è ideale e il
L'Istituto nazionale di fisica nucleare
queste due realtà io sono cresciuta come
fisico ma anche come donna soprattutto E
perché tutta la vita che nel momento in
cui uno ritiene che questa è la sua
propensione la sua passione continua ora
Che cos'è il CERN il CERN è un istituto
che è stato creato nel dove si studiano
le particelle elementari cioè tutto
quello di cui è fatto il nostro universo
e è stato formato nel
1954 da 12 stati membri e possiamo
considerare Ricordate il 1954 seconda
guerra mondiale cioè venivamo da un
periodo in cui la scienza era stata
praticamente
deviata verso altri Altri gol che erano
quelli purtroppo della ricerca militare
e quindi è diventata qualcosa di invece
importante e lo chiamo ideale perché è
un mondo in questo laboratorio
lavorano circa 20.000 persone che
provengono oggi da 110 Nazioni e
lavorano tutti insieme quindi se voi
Vedete qui potete vedere che ci sono
persone che sono in che vengono da
nazionalità dai
etnia da religioni completamente diverse
Ma che riescono a lavorare insieme ed è
questa secondo me il valore aggiunto non
è solo il fatto di fare la ricerca
l'altro valore aggiunto questo è
qualcosa che diciamo abbiamo tutti
studiato a scuola cioè praticamente il
questo palco noi stessi quel monitor
sono fatti da queste strutture e tutta
la materia è fatta fondamentalmente se
uno volesse prendere dei LEGO da tre
colori che sarebbero i due cuor
capendown e gli elettroni in realtà
questo era quello che noi conoscevamo
negli anni 60 più o meno quando
nascevo E che cosa è successo da quel
momento in poi ho avuto fortuna perché
qui microscopi che io vedevo quando ero
bambina
continuato a poterli vedere e andare a
vedere microscopi di sempre maggiore
di sempre Maggiore Potenza qui è una
visione aerea dove c'è il lago lemano i
praticamente la pista dell'aeroporto di
Ginevra e questo è tutto il complesso
dei degli acceleratori che sono 49 km e
acceleratori al di sotto i 100 metri di
profondità e
ora che cosa succede questa è la stessa
visione qui vediamo di nuovo il la pista
dell'aeroporto Ma qui siamo sotto terra
perché è importante è importante non
solo perché noi andiamo a fare delle
scoperte Ma qui quelli che voi Vedete
qui è un tunnel di 27 km di
circonferenza dove ci sono
dei
magneti superconduttori magneti
superconduttori non è qualcosa che voi
andate in un negozio lo comprate Ma ci
sono delle menti che hanno lavorato in
questo e ci sono delle
Industrie italiane che l'hanno prodotto
un terzo questo è prodotto dalla Ansaldo
in Italia quindi c'è anche un ritorno
tecnologico un ritorno verso l'industria
ma torniamo alla parte della fisica
purtroppo Allora qui vedete queste due
cose vi dicevo Appunto ci stanno questi
magneti superconduttori e i protoni che
interagiscono fra di loro passano
all'interno di questi tubi che sono dei
tubi praticamente
piccolissimi e il il questo acceleratore
lo possiamo considerare come il posto in
cui più caldo dell'universo infatti la
temperatura che si raggiunge e circa
100.000 volte maggiore di quella del
del Sole e allo stesso tempo anche il
posto più freddo dell'universo perché
per poter tenere all'interno di questi
tubi a vuoto i protoni bisogna andare a
queste temperature
Ora ancora una visione Questo è di nuovo
l'acceleratore che cosa succede ci sono
quattro punti di interazione dove questi
protoni condono e due di questi il
rivelatore Atlas il rivelatore CMS sono
quelli che hanno portato alla scoperta
del
Bosone di X ora questi rivelatori sono
rivelatori di estrema complessità vi
farò vedere dopo una figura di uno di
questi rivelatori Ve lo dovete
immaginare come praticamente una cipolla
in cui
ci sono tanti strati all'interno e
quindi quando noi andiamo a vedere poi
le particelle le tracce praticamente le
vediamo all'interno di questo complesso
oggetto ora che cosa succede Questo è
per esempio il
l'esperimento CMS che è di una
equivalente a un'altezza di 15 metri
Quindi praticamente equivalente a circa
5 piani di un di un palazzo è una
lunghezza di 21 metri e come se fosse un
palazzo che noi abbiamo ma in tutto
questo abbiamo cose di estrema
complessità tecnologica quindi
all'interno abbiamo circa 200 metri
quadri di rivelatore a silicio
immaginate che all'interno dei vostri
telefonini c'è una piccola quantità del
chip che è al silicio lì abbiamo 200
metri quadri un appartamento di silicio
e così di seguito
e poi quello che succede È che non so se
si vede qui ma praticamente L'uomo la
donna che sia ha una dimensione
piccolissima rispetto a tutto il resto
questa è una raffigurazione di come la
nostra cioè di quando noi andiamo a
vedere
le interazioni Cioè che cosa succede
quando noi abbiamo questi protoni che
fra di loro con l'ivano e vi ricordo ad
una dimensione il punto di collisione di
una dimensione minore di un capello
quello che succede se voi vi ricordate
quella
formula che si vede spesso sulle
magliette è uguale a m c quadro Noi
siamo a velocità pari alla velocità
della luce e quindi la massa è uguale a
energia e viceversa l'energia uguale in
massa Il che vuol dire che tutto quello
che noi abbiamo qui Praticamente sono
nuovi prodotti che vengono fuori da
questa collisione tra i due
tra i due fasci di protoni questo
succede 40 milioni di volte al secondo e
quindi è come se voi avete una macchina
fotografica il vostro del vostro
telefonino ma invece di fare una
fotografia una volta al secondo fate 40
milioni di fotografia al secondo potete
immaginare la complessità non solo dal
punto di vista
scientifico ma soprattutto da un punto
di vista tecnologico
ora che cosa ha portato tutto questo
vi avevo detto che abbiamo Quindi il
mondo che ci circonda è fatto
fondamentalmente da tre particelle In
realtà noi abbiamo
visto tantissime altre particelle che si
mettono all'interno di quello che viene
chiamato modello standard ma all'interno
di questo modello tutte le particelle
sarebbero senza Massa quindi noi non non
avremmo Massa assolutamente questi due
Allegri signori Peter handler è Scusate
Peter François handler Nel 1964 possono
una teoria che dice che praticamente
tutto ciò che ci circonda esiste perché
esiste un campo di X con il quale noi
interagiamo ed è quello che ci dà la
massa a tutti noi
ora chiaramente quando loro l'hanno
detto l'hanno presi anche un po' diciamo
così
Però naturalmente Era necessario cercare
di avere una
perché una teoria Sia valida c'è bisogno
di una parte sperimentale e quindi
questi esperimenti appunto CMS Atlas in
del 2012 hanno scoperto che in realtà
questi due Allegri signori che nel
frattempo sono diventati molto più
anziani in realtà esisteva ed è vista in
questo diagramma tramite questo
questo Picco che poi diventa 10 anni
dopo in questo modo cioè ogni 40 milioni
di interazioni che noi abbiamo abbiamo
un bosone di Higgs che si forma per ora
e questo ha portato al premio Nobel per
la fisica nel 2013
ora quindi praticamente che cosa noi
abbiamo abbiamo che questo acceleratore
che è questo acceleratore di particelle
in realtà forse l'avete letto su vari
giornali e la macchina che riproduce in
laboratorio il big bang perché Perché è
il solo momento in cui si va
all'indietro nel tempo e si riesce a
riprodurre quello che noi vediamo nel
laboratorio per esempio con i telescopi
si riesce ad andare invece solo ad altre
ad altre cioè sappiamo che la vita del
pianeta è di 13.8 miliardi di anni oggi
e questo si può vedere che in realtà
invece solo con la macchina lhc noi
riusciamo ad andare a vedere proprio i
primi momenti dell'universo è chiaro che
Uno potrebbe dire ma adesso avete
scoperto i Bossoni di x
pianeta in realtà non è così perché ogni
qualvolta noi facciamo una scoperta c'è
sempre una nuova scoperta di fronte a
noi Considerate che quello che noi oggi
conosciamo e solo il 4% della totale che
esiste nell'universo il resto c'è un 26%
che è dato da materie oscura è un'altra
parte che data da Energy oscura Ma
questo è un altro argomento da trattare
eventualmente un'altra volta ora quello
che volevo ricollegarmi con quello che
ha detto il sindaco perché è una delle
parti a cui io ci tengo molto e il fatto
che quando noi quello che è molto
importante è vedere tanti giovani
lavorare insieme
Considerate che questa attività che è
fatta da 4000 persone abbiamo che di
queste 4.000 persone la maggioranza sono
in realtà persone con un'età media di 27
anni quindi sono
ricercatori giovani ricercatori oppure
dottorandi e come vedete sono
distribuiti in tutto il mondo Questo
preso la collaborazione CMS a cui io
appartengo e qui vedete praticamente in
blu tutte le parti Dove la
collaborazione esiste
e vi dicevo che praticamente facciamo
abbiamo 40 milioni di
eventi al secondo questo che cosa vuol
dire che abbiamo bisogno di una una
quantità di calcolo enorme e questo ha
portato a quello che voi conoscete avete
sentito dire big data ma quello che
dovete tener presente è che ogni
qualvolta Noi andiamo a fare questo
Quindi come c'è la parte tecnologica per
quanto riguarda gli acceleratori i campi
i magneti la parte tecnologica per
quanto riguarda questo due vorrei
nominare due cose famose che hanno
sconvolto la vita che sono stati
sicuramente un nuovo inizio
Uno è il web che è stato inventato al
chernon nel 1989 io quando sono arrivata
lì come giovane dottoranda praticamente
mi lo usavamo per comunicare fra di noi
senza il web oggi senza Internet Il
mondo non funzionerebbe e se noi siamo
riusciti a superare il periodo del covip
eccetera e anche dovuto a questo l'altra
cosa diciamo noi degli acceleratori
tutto sommato che cosa ci interessa il
70% degli acceleratori che noi
utilizziamo Però più bassa energia in
realtà si trova negli ospedali serve per
radio radio
radiazione diciamo su sui per il tumore
servono anche la PET la risonanza
magnetica nucleare per esempio il
magnete che noi usiamo in CMS un magnete
di quattro Tesla Uno potrebbe dire a me
anche la risonanza magnetica nucleare a
quattro Tesla In realtà ha un fattore di
scala completamente diverso quindi è lì
che si vede la differenza
e qui L'altra cosa importante secondo me
è che quando noi conosciamo qualcosa e
vogliamo andare avanti tutto ciò che è
importante è questo e questa gente qui
Cioè non è importante Solo il fatto di
fare una scoperta è importante il fatto
che persone che provengono da nazioni
che sono eventualmente in guerra fra
loro lavorano insieme in cooperazione e
competizione ma competizione
produttiva diciamo E che dobbiamo
evitare tutto ciò che è praticamente una
diversità dovuta al genere dovuta
all'etnia qualunque alla religione
qualunque tipo di
quindi solo tanta gente tutti insieme
può determinare questi grandi successi e
quindi ritornando
da dove sono partita Sono partita con un
piccolo microscopio e sono andata a
lavorare più potente microscopio del
mondo e quindi
soprattutto per me è stato il
raggiungimento del mio sogno per quanto
riguarda gli studi del dei misteri
dell'universo ora la cosa importante per
in tutto questo messaggio Secondo me è
il fatto che io vorrei il sogno di oggi
mio è forse l'utopia di vedere
tantissime nuove generazioni qui vedo
tanti ragazzi che possano non
necessariamente essere ricercatori di
cicatrici in questo campo ma che possono
avere e procedere avanti in termini di
conoscenza perché solo con la conoscenza
riusciremo a migliorare il mondo che
intorno a noi Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]